North Korea is perhaps the most hermetic,
closed off and isolated country on the planet.
A country that now, in 2018, seems to be living
in 1960.
However, now this entire story may be about
to change.
Here at VISUALPOLITIK, we’ve already talked
about how capitalism is reaching North Korea
by following popular markets, how an entire
entrepreneurial revolution is taking place
and how today more than 50% of North Koreans
make a living from the private economy.
However, a couple of questions remained on
the table...
What does one of the most totalitarian governments
on the planet think about this particular
capitalist revolution?
What are its plans?
And another very, very important question.
Who the hell would be willing to invest in
North Korea?
Listen up.
(THESE AREN’T THE BEST OF TIMES)
On June 12th, 2018, a historic meeting was
held in Singapore...
For the first time, the US President, in this
case Donald Trump, met with a North Korean
leader.
Why?
Supposedly to denuclearize North Korea.
Perhaps the actual goal?
Well, in addition to taking a couple of pictures
– hey! more pictures never hurt - starting
a dialogue, cooling down the enormous tension
that had been growing between them, and preventing
North Korea from continuing with a nuclear
program that could have given it the ability
to attack even the United States.
Of course... just a moment because theory
is one thing, and truth, something very different.
Check out the latest news:
( “U.S. spy agencies: North Korea is working
on new missiles.
Washington Post)
(“Secretary of State Mike Pompeo acknowledged
during Senate testimony that North Korean
factories “continue to produce fissile material”
used in making nuclear weapons”.
Washington Post.)
And nowadays, as we told you here on VISUALPOLITIK,
it seems a bit difficult for the Pyongyang
regime to agree – at least in the short
term – to get rid of all its nuclear weapons,
which are, after all, their best life insurance.
But... of course, that doesn’t mean that
he won’t accept making concessions to normalize
his relations with the rest of the world and
end international sanctions.
Because, you see... since Kim Jong Un came
to power in 2011, he’s had two priorities:
developing the nuclear bomb... and something
far less sinister... reforming the economy.
Yes, you heard that right.
Although it seems hard to believe, one of
the objectives that Kim Jong-Un, the North
Korean dictator, has set himself is to change
his country’s bad economic situation by
copying some of the changes that have taken
place in countries like China and Vietnam.
And, check this out, once they develop their
nuclear capabilities…
Pyongyang’s number one priority is precisely
this-- to advance in economic development.
Of course... to achieve this they need to
end international sanctions... which are causing
enormous damage.
Yes, we’ll see how, though it may seem hard
to believe, North Korea’s situation could
get worse.
For example, check out what happened to the
trade relations between North Korea and Latin
America... between the sanctions and the sinking
of Venezuela - one of the few countries that
had allied itself with North Korea - relations
have collapsed:
But... of course... when we talk about North
Korea and the economy, we need to talk about
China: 80% of all North Korean trade and foreign
exchange occurs here.
And what’s happened is that China has been
pushing Pyongyang for years to get some reforms
going once and for all.
And since those changes have been slower than
a turtle with rheumatism, well… last year
Beijing decided to start applying international
sanctions...
This is what was happening in August 2017:
(China to Implement UN Sanctions on North
Korea”.
Fox News)
( China bans North Korean iron, lead, coal
imports as part of U.N. sanctions.
Washington Post)
As you can imagine, considering the enormous
dependence that North Korea has on China this
has been a disaster.
Just in the first 6 months of 2018 Chinese
purchases of North Korean products have plummeted
by more than 90%... and Chinese exports to
North Korea by 40%.
All this, of course, in the official market...
as we’ve seen, there’s a parallel market,
the black market, but that's a different story.
The fact is that all this has led North Korean
industrial and mining production to go through
its worst time in years.
And if we add the disastrous state of the
country’s infrastructure to all this...
with their continuous blackouts, less than
1,000 km of paved roads throughout the country
and decrepit trains that, in many cases, don’t
go over 20 km or 12 miles per hour... it’s
clear that this country urgently needs a 180-degree
turn...
And you know what?
They know this in Pyongyang.
(CAN NORTH KOREA BECOME THE NEW VIETNAM?)
In 1986 Vietnam launched the well-known Doi
Moi policy, a set of economic reforms similar
to those of Deng Xiaoping in China, which
had the mission of setting communism aside
to jump-start a market economy.
To achieve this, agricultural cooperatives
were dissolved, price controls were eliminated,
land ownership was allowed, and policies were
put in place to attract foreign investment.
So what was the result?
Over the following 30 years, Vietnam's economy
grew at an annual average of almost 7%.
Today Vietnam is transforming at a breakneck
speed and its exports are already larger than
those of countries like Brazil or Australia.
Well... at the last inter-Korean summit in
April between Kim Jong Un and the president
of South Korea, Moon Jae-in, the North Korean
leader expressed an interest in following
the model of....
Vietnam.
And following this line, the North Korean
government has approved some significant measures
in recent years:
for example, it has promoted the creation
of private markets, has given more autonomy
to public companies and has granted land parcels
for the peasants’ private exploitation.
However... despite all this, there are two
questions we need to answer: Who on earth
would be willing to invest in North Korea?
And what else is the Pyongyang government
willing to do?
Listen up.
(WHO WOULD INVEST IN NORTH KOREA?)
If you were asked which countries you’d
like to do business in, North Korea would
probably be one of your last options...
Investing in such a totalitarian country,
where the leader makes and unmakes at will,
where the government acts with brutality and
dedicates itself to threatening the rest of
the planet?
Investing in a country where the rule of law
and legal security are pure fantasy?
Come on!
Well... folks, the truth is that not everyone
sees it this way.
See, some of South Korea's largest companies
such as Hyundai, Lotte Corporation and Samsung
have already set up workgroups to investigate
and analyze potential business opportunities
in North Korea.
And according to polls, three-quarters of
South Korean companies would be willing to
invest in the north if sanctions were lifted.
Hyundai, for example, is already preparing
an early reopening of the industrial Kaesong
zone, an industrial zone next to the border
of South Korea that was created in 2004 to
house foreign companies – mainly South Korean
– and which employed more than 80,000 North
Koreans...
But in 2013, given the growing tensions between
the two Koreas, it was closed by the Pyongyang
government.
Even recently, Jim Rogers, one of the most
important and well-known investors of all
time, has lamented the fact that the United
States doesn’t allow him to invest in North
Korea and has made statements such as these:
(“Korea is now going to be the most exciting
country in the world.
Kim Jong-Un does not want war.
Kim is not North Korean.
He was educated in Switzerland.
He knows there’s a different world out there.
“They need everything … electricity … soap
… tablecloths,...
[...] If you’ve got any kind of expertise
you’re going to make a fortune.”
Jim Rogers)
But wait just a moment... the question we
have to ask ourselves is, what the hell do
they see in a country like North Korea?
Well... fundamentally, opportunities.
Allow me to explain.
North Korea has a relatively young, very entrepreneurial
population with very low labor costs.
In addition, the country seems to be quite
rich in natural resources: gold, zinc, copper,
rare earth elements… the estimated value
of all mineral resources is more than 6 billion
dollars.
Then, as Jim Rogers says, the country is being
built.
It needs everything.
And if that weren’t enough, it’s also
located between two economic powers, China
and South Korea.
See, at the last inter-Korean summit, the
South Korean President gave Kim Jong-Un a
pen drive that included lots of the investments
that South Korea would be willing to make.
Do you know what investments were included
on this pen drive?
Well, for example, Seoul would be very interested
in building trans-Korean railroads that, in
addition to boosting the North Korean economy,
would allow South Korea to export goods much
more quickly to China.
And the same with roads, oil pipelines, etc.,
etc.... these would be billion-dollar plans.
Of course... not everything is so simple and
enthusiasm is far from widespread.
North Korea is a brutal dictatorship, corruption
is huge and the government can do, literally
whatever it wants.
For example, expropriate:
(TEXT: Well, be careful with your answers,
you know?
Because you’re telling me that the bank
isn’t for sale but I can expropriate it
if I want.)
(“This is where the money is to be made…
if you can figure out how not to get expropriated.”
Justin Hastings, an associate professor at
the University of Sydney)
And then, of course, there’s the issue of
international sanctions... as a consequence
of the nuclear program.
And, until they are lifted… any change will
have a very short run.
Now, it’s precisely at this point that China
can play a very important role.
You see, Xi Jinping has managed to do what
China’s been planning for years: getting
Pyongyang going.
Which could obviously mean big business for
Chinese companies.
That’s why we now see headlines like this.
(China suggests sanctions relief for North
Korea after Trump-Kim summit.
CNBC)
And not only that, China has allowed the black
market between both countries to flourish,
has accelerated the development plans in the
border area and is already studying the imminent
opening of special economic zones on the North
Korean border...
And then there’s tourism... which is precisely
one of Kim Jong Un's government’s greatest
priorities.
Listen up.
(NORTH KOREA, A HOLIDAY SPOT?)
The arrival of Chinese tourists has continued
growing in recent years and since May 2019
the number of daily arrivals has more than
doubled.
(“We are going to run at least seven or
eight tour routes to North Korea this year,
including a one-day tour to Nanyo and a trip
of four to five days to Pyongyang, Kaesong
and Panmunjom”.
- Che Jing, a deputy manager of a chinese
travel company.)
Well... tourism is precisely one of the Pyongyang
government’s top priorities... for several
reasons:
first it generates employment – remember
this is a very labor-intensive sector – attracts
investment and helps obtain foreign currency
quickly.
On the other hand tourism could change the
regime’s image… and, the truth is that
swapping nuclear parades and nuclear threats
with exotic beaches and seaside dinners…
would be good for business.
Due to this, in 2014 the North Korean government
created the Special Tourist Zone of Wonsan,
a special economic zone where foreign investment
is allowed and where in principle, the regime
would allow more freedom for developing tourism.
Yes, this is the same area where until recently
the army did things like this.
You know, North Korean things.
The fact is that with the nuclear program
and the sanctions, results have been very
scarce... however Kim Jong Un wants to step
on the gas.
Without going any further, in 2017 the North
Korean government sent a delegation to Spain,
which is one of the major tourist powers of
the world, to check out places like Benidorm
or Marina d'Or [Marina Door], to learn from
them and get some ideas.
You heard that right.
Apparently, Pyongyang’s goal is to attract
more than 1 million tourists per year in the
short term and 5 to 10 million in the reasonable
future.
The question is, will Kim Jong-Un really be
willing to carry out all the reforms that
the country needs so that all these plans
can come to life?
Folks, only the future can answer that question.
For now, what seems clear is that we have
the best opportunity to leave the North Korean
nightmare behind, which isn’t only a threat
to the rest of the world but above all a punishment
and a great prison of fear and repression
for North Koreans themselves.
But now... it’s your turn, are you in favor
of lifting sanctions against North Korea?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, thanks for watching!